somebody
you know strung together examples of him
saying the n-word
and unearthed jokes that uh
that make him look racist
obviously it's a these are propaganda
videos engineered to make him look as
racist as possible by lifting something
out of context
still they look bad
and basically it's just you know people
want his head people want his head on a
stick
and
i am very against cancel culture i think
the way to engage people is to
criticize
the misinformation that they've
uh that that they believe i think
joe rogan is an extraordinarily
open-minded person
he has a relationship to correcting
errors and apologizing
that almost
no one else in at his level of media has
right he's a person that can say i got
it wrong
and does this often
in a way that is really credible and
honest
and
really admirable because he's such a
genuine person he has such a
relationship to his audience where they
know he means exactly what he says
which you can't say of any of the cable
news people
that are reaching um probably fewer
people than he is
and because he has such a good
relationship to the truth even when he
gets stuff wrong
i think i mean it it's insane to people
that p to me that people are holding him
to a totally separate standard that they
would hold
uh you know a cable news show
all of which have also spread
misinformation to varying degrees
throughout the pandemic right
tucker carlson says some [ __ ] or don
lemon says some [ __ ]
they don't have to worry
that their show is going to be taken off
the network
right whereas joe rogan because he
signed this deal with spotify partly
and because he's frankly a lot of people
in the mainstream media i think are
envious and competitive of the amount of
people he reaches
and then a lot of people that don't like
the fact that he's not completely
left-wing obviously
um
he gets hate from the mainstream media
who don't really defend him as like a
fellow ally as someone we want to
protect because he's doing what we do
and then he gets hate obviously from the
cancel culture left
um because he's not left and i think i
think it's it's it's really dangerous i
think we have to hold the line for
people like joe rogan
um or else we lose the norm of
free speech and i know the second you
say free speech people are gonna say
it's not this is not relevant to the
first amendment the government isn't
trying to censor him
yes but
the reason the first amendment makes
sense is because of this wider point
that free speech is a very good thing
for society open discourse as a general
cultural
value is an important thing for society
and that means free speech for speech
you don't always like and i think that's
very important
what do you think about some of the more
right-wing commentators online that have
been saying
don't back down don't apologize for
anything this is not the way to play the
game
so
they would be right for a lot of
people it you know these days it does
not make sense for a politician to
apologize
no one believes it
biden apologizes no one believes it
trump apologizes well he never
apologizes
but if he did no one would believe it
because
you know imagine hillary clinton
apologizing does anyone in the world go
oh my god that's amazing that she can
see
that she's evolved so much as a person
no it's it's so clearly scripted right
and frankly i think
any apology from normal media figures is
going to seem scripted
the difference with joe rogan is he this
is the joe rogan effect right
his apologies
are real you can you can just hear it
you can see that he
he really thinks he should have had more
people on from a provac's perspective
um
he is doing his best
and
his apologies are
he's one of the only people at his level
of media reach that can apologize in a
way that does not seem scripted and
seems credible
and
as as a human being i think the ability
to apologize is extremely important
and that holds for your friends that
holds for your relationships
and it should hold if you have a really
honest relationship with your audience
with which joe rogan does to an
exceptional degree so i disagree with
those i think his apology came across
uh extremely well
i think that
there's definitely a a different element
to when joe apologizes versus when other
people do it i think the concern from
people on the right is that
by
apologizing you lend credence or
legitimacy to people that want to
censor free speech right
but joe is doing his apology in a very
different sort of way because of the
level of intimacy that he has between
himself and his audience and the amount
of trust
the thing that i think that's
interesting is usually when the
mainstream media try to attack somebody
with
um clips whether that be from the
like first phase of this uh campaign or
the second phase of this campaign around
covid versus the eclipse of him saying
the n-word
i think that the problem that they have
most of the time the press are trying to
show you a small microcosm of someone
that they claim is indicative of the
remainder of their character right here
is the tip of the iceberg
that shows that this person is the
racist homophobic xenophobic whatever
that we always knew that he is and
here's the proof this is the cracks
showing in his persona and this is the
actual true joe coming through you just
didn't happen to know about it the
problem that you have is that the vast
majority of people even people who are
super duper casual fans of rogan have
probably listened to
at least 100 200 300 hours and the
normal fans of him you're talking
upwards of a thousand hours easily that
someone can have consumed joe rogan's
content they go well hang on a second i
i can't take this is the tip of the
iceberg from you the whole iceberg
precisely precisely i have such a depth
of connection with this guy they've seen
the tip and the bass correct that
sounded really weird do not say that
again pause
the tip and the bass of joe um
but yeah
that's it that's what they're trying to
do they're trying to use this old media
narrative of here is the
small segment that represents the bigger
version uh but they can't do that they
can't do that anymore
yeah so it
you raise a really interesting point and
i think it's true
what separates this cancellation from
most other cancellations
is that they're not unearthing anything
there's nothing
we all know exactly who joe rogan has
been
for years now because
he has four hour conversations every day
that are completely unfiltered
where he says exactly what he thinks
right
all the evidence of him being a bad
person
if such evidence exists it's already in
the open
right there's nothing to discover
if you hate him you hate him based on
who he actually is by now
but
so compare that to like a different kind
of a cancellation
you know
generally it's it's like finding
something no one knew about right it's
like
we found this blog from 15 years ago
where joy reed from msnbc
said that you know all gay men like
underage boys right that's a true that's
a true story that happened people don't
really talk about it because
since
joy reid is a darling of the left she is
somehow immune to the logic of
cancellation
even though if joe rogan had done the
same thing people would be foaming about
foaming at the mouth about it which
again as a sidebar shows you how these
sort of cultural rules are used as
um basically
totally arbitrary rules to [ __ ] over
people you don't like and you suddenly
stop caring about them when it's
something you like that should tell you
everything you need to know about these
cancellations for things you said 20
years ago
i mean someone unearthed something of
neil young saying
something like pretty
i think it was kind of pro nazi i might
have to fact check that but he said
something really cancelable in like the
80s or 90s
and then he walked it back
um
but you know that
that's usually how cancellations work
it's like
this thing oh you didn't know roald dahl
said basically justified the holocaust
right and now you know and it makes you
think about matilda differently okay
that's usually how it works even in
those cases if a person has disavowed
their views i'm really against
cancelling them because people change so
much over the course of their lives
the difference with joe is that that's
not what's happening here it's like
they're just stitching together
non-representative out of context bits
from a long career
and playing them back to back as if all
he's been doing for the past 20 years is
saying the n word do you know where that
do you know where that super cut
originally came from
we're aware
alex jones made it
no way
alex jones made it
why do you remember when he him and
rogan had that beef
no
okay so him and rogan had a fallout a
little while ago it's like semi
semi-public it was before spotify maybe
i want to say five or four or five years
ago uh and this was alex throwing a
little bit of shade around in an
original version of this video now i
might be i might have been sold a lie by
the version of the video that i've seen
and if that's the case then sorry alex
but
uh it's i've heard from a bunch of
different sources that the original
video was from alex jones and if you
actually look at the first first first
version it's got infowars graphics on it
and this was him throwing that around so
the interesting thing i'd seen this
video
a bunch of times it's been floating
around twitter for quite a while and
i've seen it i've seen it do the rounds
a fair bit but there's equivalent
versions of this for the young turks
there's a huge one of them floating
around at the moment that's got one and
a half million plays on it they're just
same thing out of context n word n word
n word n word n word there's uh ethan
klein when he tried to when he deleted
some of jordan peterson's episodes with
him a couple of weeks ago he said both
the n-word and the f-word back-to-back
over and over again
i really love saying
did any like
okay
but then the super cut of joe
for whatever reason
decides to really really get a lot of
momentum and gravitas now one of the
things that i definitely don't think is
true that i've seen in a bunch of
different group chats i'm in is that
this is part of some overarching
conspiracy there's some company the one
that's behind patriot takes which is the
twitter account that did it they're in
support of some other super pac
organization that is linked with blah
blah blah and uh
stool presidente who's the guy that owns
bar still sports
dude that owns barstool sports went on i
know i know who you're talking about
went on a uh live stream podcast with
the guys that own that company that is
associated with this and he's going
backward and forward i don't think that
there's i don't think you need to look
to conspiracy to see why these two
things happened in
um sequence with each other especially
if
as i said this video has been floating
around for a long time and it wasn't
created by somebody i think that you've
primed the uh like cultural algorithm
with joe rogan's done something wrong
and he's done an apology video and then
people have taken this opportunity to go
right okay now i'm gonna try and throw
yeah precisely
what have we got yep what else can we
throw at him there's videos floating
around of
other stuff as well uh are you not gonna
everyone's talking about joe rogan's
racism but what about his misogyny here
he is laughing at one of his comedian
friends saying that he used to get
sucked off in the back room of the
comedy store
and it's just what can you find over a
twelve years
yeah i know uh over a 12 of a 15-year
career of having whatever
10 hours of conversations a week
like 2 000 podcast episodes um
but it's hard it's hard to say
it's not the individual words in context
the way that you do that it's not
forgivable or at least it's not it
shouldn't be like something that we
support but as somebody that puts out an
awful lot of content i know that as your
volume increases you're gonna say dumb
stuff over and over and over again and
uh over a long enough period of time
there's gonna be a lot of dumb stuff and
that's how you make like a huge
supercomputer if you're a comedian
that's often having other comedians on
your podcast drinking smoking weed on
your podcast it's an informal
conversation
they're not putting together uh you know
like you know 99 theses of like what
they think about the world all the time
a lot of times they're [ __ ] around
that's why people like it
um
you know listen i think we have to also
talk about
the issue of whether it is
in all cases immoral or unethical
to say the n word
right
people are i think pretending not to
understand the difference between
mentioning a word in quotations
and
directing a slur
at somebody right with malicious intent
those are two very different things and
it's two very different people
that do either one of those
and i think people are disingenuously
pretending not to know the difference
between those two things pretending not
to be able to observe the difference
and you know it's so interesting i
finally watched the o.j simpson
documentary
um last week
and
there's this moment in the o.j simpson
trial
where
there's this huge fight over whether
they can admit
mark furman's n-word tape right this
this cop that got that found the glove
at the scene had a history of saying the
n-word
the oj's defense said we want the jury
to hear him say the n-word so that they
don't trust his testimony right
and the prosecution said we don't want
them to to hear the n-word right it's
going to bias their judgment and there's
this argument about it
and and the prosecution says essentially
to the judge when black people hear the
n-word they cannot remain objective
it's too emotional
it's too
it's too hard-hitting
there's no black juror can remain
objective after hearing that word and
jurors need to remain objective
then oj's defense comes back and says
how dare you say black people can't
remain unbiased after hearing the n-word
how dare you it's racist it's
patronizing it's condescending
and they were widely thought to have won
that particular argument right back in
the 90s
the version of 90s woke that that
obtained during the oj trial said of
course black people can hear the n word
in certain contexts and understand it
and remain objective right remain
unbiased remain rational
what i find interesting now is that
people are implicitly making the
argument of the prosecution now
as woke which is that if black people
hear the n-word it's it hurts too much
we can't possibly remain rational enough
to observe the difference between
someone mentioning it
in quotation marks
and somebody directing it as a slur
of of course people can
and i think
you know this is where the cynicism
comes into this it's like
the notion of black people taking
offense at rogan saying this word
is
i think being used cynically to take him
down do you not think that any black
people have taken offense at it oh sure
i i definitely think some black people
have taken offense at it
um probably
black people that are less familiar with
him
right like if this is this goes back to
the iceberg question
if this is the tip of the iceberg that
you're seeing joe rogan about you're
gonna think he's a racist he made a
jokes about a joke about going to a
black neighborhood and um it's seeming
like planet of the apes right
and then it's just like edward edward
edward
um
so if again if that's the tip of the
iceberg you are rationally going to
think wow this guy has just been like
foaming at the mouth with racism for
years
and and that that it makes sense makes
perfect sense to take offense to that as
a black person or as any person
if you're familiar with much more of the
iceberg
as a lot of people probably are
and joe rogan has a lot of black fans
i don't think they're taking offense
because
uh
i mean they just they know his general
character
so well at this point
they're not getting new data about his
character right they know he's a
comedian that says
says every curse word
makes fun of every group
so like imagine
this is this is very interesting imagine
you had never seen the show south park
and it's gone what over 20 seasons right
similar to joe rogan in that they have a
[ __ ] ton of material
and you stitch together every joke at
black people's expense ever made on the
show south park and you have no other
familiarity with it
you are going to come away thinking how
the [ __ ] is this on tv is this show from
the [ __ ] jim crow south
like my god
now of course the rest of us that have
watched a lot of south park
we understand they make fun of everyone
they make fun of everyone right we've
seen the whole iceberg
that's what's happening to joe rogan
right now so yeah i assume a lot of
black people to the extent they're
seeing
a small sliver
of what he's done are taking offense but
again it is it is propaganda this is the
definition of propaganda
and
i think
that should be more widely understood
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you